- All these false stories.
This kid comes from a family
with family members
of multiple races.
They did a deep dive on
all of his social media.
They did a colonoscopic kind
of review of his social media
and they found no connections
to any form of
racism of any kind,
no connections to
militia of any kind,
no connections to anybody
like that of any kind,
no statements like
that at any time.
All they had was that he had
once gone to a Trump rally.
That was their sole basis,
the, "Oh, you went
to a Trump rally,"
and like most-
- Well, there you go.
- Exactly, and he's
a gun supporter
and he's a police,
military supporter,
and that was it, but
all they just did,
most of the media ran with
these false allegations,
these stream of false,
to this day, they continue
to tell false stories,
the prosecutors continue
to lie about 'em
using court proceedings
to get away with the lie.
The kid's the most innocent
defendant I've ever represented,
ever been involved with, but
the case goes far past him.
If he gets convicted,
self-defense is dead in America.
(gentle music)
- I'm Dave Rubin and joining
me today is a trial lawyer
and an all-star
political gambler,
also a primo promoter
of locals.com.
Robert Barnes, welcome
back to "The Rubin Report."
- Glad to be here.
- I am glad to have you, man.
I didn't realize until
literally two minutes ago
that we have not spoken
in a one-on-one forum
for over two years.
Is the world getting better
or worse in those two years?
- Back then, I was taking a
lot of controversial cases.
We were talking about Alex
Jones, the Covington kids,
Wesley Snipes, Ralph
Nader, Girls Gone Wild,
all the rest of it,
so I decided to take
less controversial cases,
so I took Donald Trump
(Dave laughing)
during the elections,
Amy Cooper in New York,
Kyle Rittenhouse, self-defense,
but yeah, the world just
keeps getting crazier,
particularly from a legal
political perspective.
- Yeah, so what
put you on the map?
Is it fair to say that what
originally put you on the map
in a bigger sense
was the bet on Trump?
Is that really the thing
that got you out there
as more of a public lawyer?
- Yeah. Yeah.
Basically, I'd always
done a lot of tax work,
but for a lot of reasons,
I didn't need that
to be high profile,
and I'd done a lot
of civil rights work
but had not made
myself a public figure,
but people had
followed the Trump bet
because it was a big
bet and the rest,
became a public figure,
and during the
Trump time period,
it became more important
to be a public figure
defending certain issues in
the court of public opinion.
- Yeah, and now you're
an all-star YouTuber
who hangs out like this all day,
(Robert laughing)
like world, come at me.
I want to get into
some of those cases
that you've covered, obviously,
but let's start with
Trump's current lawsuit
because just in the
last 10 days or so,
he has announced that he's
basically going after Big Tech
in a class action lawsuit,
and not just Big Tech,
but actually some of the
heads of these companies.
Can you give people the 101,
the sort of must have info on
what the lawsuit actually is,
and then we'll talk about
the chances of it succeeding?
- Sure, so basically, Trump
has brought a claim saying
that all the Big
Tech giants conspired
with various government actors
to kick him off
of and exclude him
from all of their platforms,
and he is saying that they
did so as state actors
and thus are subject to
First Amendment limitations.
That's the core of his
claim against Google,
against Facebook
and against Twitter,
as well as Dorsey, Zuckerberg,
and the Google CEO individually.
- The key there seems
to be some kind of
collusion with the government.
He's not arguing just that
Twitter, Facebook and Instagram
all sat down and
maybe did something,
but somehow there was a
connection to the government.
Do you have any idea if
there's evidence of that
or what he could actually
prove that would show it?
- I think they may, in
an amended complaint,
make better
allegations factually,
but there's inferential evidence
that Fauci, Pelosi and Harris
had specifically requested
each of those platforms
to remove Trump from
those platforms.
Some of that's based on some
of their public statements.
of the emails that came out
from the FOIA request
with Fauci and Zuckerberg.
There was much more collusion.
Some of that is
indirectly referenced
by Robert Kennedy's
suit against Facebook
pending in California about
the same set of allegations.
I think if they make
better allegations,
they may be able to get to the
discovery stage and find out
just how much these Big
Tech giants were operating
at the direct request
of government actors.
- Before we get to discovery,
which obviously is the
interesting part of this,
why is he doing it
as a class action
and not just him going
after them for how he was,
in his eyes, basically wronged.
- I think his purpose in this,
his heart is in the right place.
I think some of the
lawyers involved
might not have the technical
skill to translate that well
because there could've been
a class action alleging
that Big Tech is really part
of the public digital square
and the public
square has just moved
from the physical world
to the digital world
and from the geographic
world to the online world,
and he would have had, I
think, a strong claim on that,
at least to challenge
existing law and to extend it.
They didn't really do that.
This particular class
action isn't the strongest
because what he's
alleging, really,
is that he was targeted
because he was President Trump
and he's trying to bring
all these other people in
that had been targeted
for political reasons,
but they're not President Trump.
From a pure legal perspective,
technically it's
not the best claim.
- Can you explain just
how the process works?
He now brings this class action
and how does it
get to the judge,
and is it one judge
that will decide
if this thing can go to trial?
- Effectively, here's
what's likely to happen.
They'll likely try to
move to transfer it
from the Southern District of
Florida, where he filed it,
to the Northern
District of California
on grounds that it's a
term of service dispute,
at least Twitter.
Probably Facebook and YouTube
will try that as well.
That will be his first fight-
- Meaning you get it to Cali
'cause that's where
they're based.
- Exactly, and they have some
contractual language that can,
depending on the nature of
the claim, require that.
They're gonna want
a different district
court judge assigned
and a different
court of appeals.
They'll want the Ninth Circuit,
not the Eleventh Circuit.
They'll also want
anti-SLAPP law to apply,
which doesn't apply in Florida,
but it would apply
in California,
because that would
make Trump responsible
for the other side's
legal fees if he loses.
That will be his
first big battle.
The second battle would
be a motion to dismiss
before it ever gets to
class certification stage.
If he wins at that level,
then he gets discovery,
and then after that,
a single judge usually
decides whether or not
there's class certification.
He's got several procedural
hurdles to get through first.
- Who decides that part?
Because it seems to
me that this thing,
even if Trump doesn't win, if
it at least gets to discovery,
we're gonna find out something.
If Twitter and
Facebook and YouTube
have to open up the
books and really show,
oh, members of Congress or the
Senate or the administration
were actually DMing people,
coordinating some of this stuff,
or whatever else it's showing
related to
manipulating algorithms
or shadow banning
or anything else,
it's like that's the win,
even if it's not a legal win.
How do we at least get there?
- Basically, he needs to
enhance the complaint.
I think he should add
some lawyers to the team,
like Alan Dershowitz,
like Harmeet Dhillon.
Harmeet Dhillon has a very good
state action Twitter
claim currently pending,
so add some lawyers who are
familiar with this space
and change his complaint.
His complaint as
it currently exists
won't get him past
a motion to dismiss,
but if they add to it,
I think he has good
grounds to allege
that these individual
actors were acting
at the direct request of
Vice President Kamala Harris
and of speaker of the
House, Nancy Pelosi,
and maybe of Anthony
Fauci in other contexts,
and then I think he
can get to discovery,
and you're absolutely right.
There's gonna be a lot
of revelatory discovery
if he can get to that stage.
I hope he improves the case
so that he can
get to that stage.
- I sense you think
maybe he doesn't have
the best legal representatives
around him right now,
the way you're describing it.
- No.
It's one of these groups
that's a DC-based group,
that their roots are in big
oil, corporate lobbying.
If you wanted a regulatory
issue on energy,
they're fantastic.
First Amendment constitutional
issue on Big Tech,
that's not their
area or focal point.
I think these lawyers are
lawyers that are unfamiliar
with this space and it
showed up in the suit,
and right now, those of us
that are familiar in this space
that want this lawsuit
to move forward
are very concerned that, as
alleged, this lawsuit is DOA.
He can improve it though.
He's got plenty of times to
amend it, but with Trump,
sometimes his personnel picks
are a little hit or miss.
- Did you think about picking
up the phone and saying,
"Hey, guys, I know a little
something about this.
We have some connections here"?
- Actually, a bunch of us did,
and it's just Trump is Trump.
He makes his decisions
at different times.
I've been telling him ever
since, actually, November
that he should be on Locals.
(Dave laughing)
If you want to compete
with all the Big Tech people,
what better way to
monetize Trump's brand?
There's so many different
ways he could do this,
but he has a lot of other
people whispering in his ear,
and I think some of the people
that are whispering in his ear
don't really want him
to succeed in his suit,
and it was a problem
throughout his four years,
that there was an angel on
one side, on one shoulder,
a devil on the other
and he doesn't always
get the best advice,
but people are
telling him that now.
I hope he takes
corrective action
before the case
can get dismissed.
- For the record, I know
you're not the only person
in somewhat of the inner circle
that has mentioned Locals
to him, and the truth is,
although it would cause us
some headaches, obviously,
and there would be
some legal issues
and technical stuff
and all of that,
he of course is
welcome on there,
and I honestly think
the guy could make
probably 250 million a month
on the idea that
50 million people
would give him
probably five bucks
to be part of that community.
It's bananas, but
he's doing his thing.
- It's the best way
to take out Big Tech.
The best way to really
take out Big Tech
is to replace Big Tech,
and I think his heart is
absolutely in the right place
in bringing this suit,
credit to him for doing so.
It doesn't translate
as well legally,
but it's another
place where he could
mount a better challenge
if he's also supporting
independent tech platforms
that are the real threat
to Big Tech longterm.
- I know we've discussed
this a little bit,
but I'm curious, in
the last two years,
if you've shifted at all.
Where are you on in
terms of regulation
or breaking 'em up or nothing
or something that
I'm not mentioning?
- Interestingly enough,
Senator Rubio has put,
it was a bill I proposed to
Senator Hawley three years ago.
Rubio has now put forward,
which makes it simple,
if Big Tech wants
Section 230 immunity,
in other words, if
you're a monopoly,
if you have more than 80%
market share in your space,
then you have to honor
First Amendment limitations,
like Locals does voluntarily.
If you honor First
Amendment limitations,
then you get Section
230 immunity,
but if you don't honor
First Amendment limitations
and you decide to censor
for political purposes,
then you don't get
Section 230 immunity.
That to me, that carrot
and stick approach,
gets around the government
regulation problem
and gets around
them getting to do
whatever they want problem.
It says, "We'll give you the
carrot of special immunity,
but it comes with a stick
that you have to honor
the First Amendment
once you acquire certain
economic influence
within the marketplace."
- Are you worried, though,
if they got rid of
those protections,
the 230 protections,
that in essence,
they would have to basically
have a team of lawyers
that would be watching what
everyone says all day long
knowing that at any given moment
someone puts child pornography
on there or some other,
a terrorist threat or something,
that bam, (fingers snapping)
they could just be sued into
oblivion and gone that day?
- Yeah, that's why
I'm not in favor
of just scratching
Section 230, my view,
and I'm not in favor of
the government regulating.
I get why people like the
idea of public utilities,
et cetera, but
look at any history
of the government
regulating anything
and see whether that
turns out net positive.
(Dave laughing)
That's why my view is give 'em,
stay within the private
marketplace incentives,
but just change the
incentives to say,
"We're gonna give you a special
benefit nobody else gets,
total immunity from suit for
anything said on your platform,
but you just have to
honor the First Amendment
and how you regulate
that platform
once you have more
than 80% market share
in your area of
the public square."
- Do you think it's possible
that, at this point,
we're like, the ship has
just sailed on all of this,
that Big Tech is now
so big, so ubiquitous,
our government is
so dysfunctional,
it's controlled by an
awful lot of people
that guys like you
and I don't like,
that the idea that they
could actually do anything,
not only make the decision
but then carry the
decision through,
is just like, it's just
bananas at this point.
- I think they still
have the capacity for it
because they show it.
The quickness with which
they got rid of Trump
was a reminder that
they can invent AI
that's First
Amendment oriented AI
to regulate their own platforms,
and that's what's also
great about Locals,
reason why I promote it,
is Locals shows you
can have a platform
that is First
Amendment compliant
that is technologically
capable of delivering
on that First Amendment
compliant tech platform,
and so if they have
problems with it,
they can look to
Locals as the example
and just borrow that
and implement it.
They clearly have the
capacity to do it.
- I gotta get you
on payroll, man,
but the truth is that the way
we've dealt with it so far,
first off, because you have
a paywall, as you know,
just a couple of bucks,
it's as little as $2,
that cleans up
99.9% of everything.
We have no problem with bots
and trolls and truly
hateful people.
It just doesn't exist,
but as I always say
to people, it's like,
"Man, if you're gonna come
on and do something illegal,
you got a much bigger
problem than me or Locals.
There's laws that exist,
so you're gonna have the
government coming after you."
You're not gonna worry about
what Dave Rubin's gonna do.
- Precisely, and what it
shows is the capacity.
Locals shows all the ability
of what would a First Amendment
supporting tech platform
look like without the stalking,
without the harassment,
without the obscenity,
without unnecessary trolling.
You can have both, the
best of both worlds,
and Locals proves it,
and that's where I think we
can use Locals as an example,
not only as an exit ramp
from Big Tech monopoly
but also as a legal
example to say,
"This is what Big Tech
should have to emulate
if they want to continue
to get special immunity
under the law."
- I heard Alan Dershowitz
talking about this case
and he did say some of the
things that you just said there,
that maybe it isn't
quite as tight as written
as it should be,
but he said that this might be
the most important First
Amendment case in modern times.
Do you agree with that?
- Oh, I agree entirely.
That's why he, I and others
want to see the suit be brought
in the best, most effective way.
Add claims for unjust enrichment
because all these companies
got rich off of Trump,
then after they got
rich off of Trump,
decided they could
politically censor him.
Add claims for consumer fraud
because all of them
lied to people.
Jack Dorsey, famously,
"I'm gonna be the
free-speech wing
of the free-speech party."
(Dave laughing)
I just want Jack Dorsey to
have to keep his promises,
and the reason why I think
Dershowitz is out there
is he's trying to get,
with Trump, you have to talk
to him through the TV cameras,
God bless him.
He'll listen to
you on the phone,
but he listens better when
it's through the TV camera.
If Dershowitz is
giving great advice,
it's absolutely one of the
most essential, critical cases
for the future of the country
'cause either we're gonna
have free speech or we're not,
and if private companies
own the public square
and it keeps going
the way it's going,
free speech will
be dead in America.
- Basically, you're saying
dealing with Trump as a client
is completely the reverse of
how you would do it normally,
where you want those
off-the-record conversations.
Trump, you gotta go
on YouTube or on TV
to tell him what
you're thinking.
- Precisely. That's the
best way he listens.
He's a unique mindset.
- Yeah, so what else legally,
we'll get into some of the
cultural stuff in a moment,
but what else legally is
on your docket right now
that you're putting
your energy into?
- A combination of efforts.
One is in terms of the
entire election context
from representing the
president during the campaign,
right after the campaign.
There's a lot of those issues
that need to be reinforced.
A lot of states are
passing good laws,
helping states pass those laws,
following up on the audits
that are taking place
because if we don't
have confidence
in our election integrity,
the entire democracy
crumbles overnight.
- Yeah, can you, just
real quick on that,
so obviously even
talking about this,
I could be blown off
YouTube in just a second,
but fortunately I am on
Locals, so it's all right.
What happened to all
of those lawsuits?
Because there seemed to be hope.
There were people that I trusted
that I feel like are
sound legal minds
that felt there was
some movement there
and then everything
just crumbled at once.
What actually happened?
- I and a group of
lawyers were that close
to getting to run
all the lawsuits,
and our focus was
that the lawsuits
were gonna be based on
the election not being run
in a constitutionally
conforming manner,
that there were votes
counted that were not,
either by someone who is not
constitutionally qualified
to vote because of age
or some other issue
or because they didn't live
at the location, et cetera,
or the ballot was
cast in a manner
that wasn't a constitutionally
qualified manner,
the signature match
check didn't conform
on an absentee
ballot, as an example,
and the ballots were not
counted and canvassed
in a constitutionally
qualified manner
that conforms to international
election standards
and the United States
Election Commission standards.
We had established
all of these claims.
We were building these suits
in all of these states.
It was the ultimate
Georgia recount case
that the president filed,
but what happened is that it
got hijacked midway through
by people who got distracted
by some shiny objects,
and people who, like
Lin Wood, Sidney Powell,
God bless them, Rudy Giuliani,
they had no election
law background,
but they felt confident
that their sources
were giving them
accurate information.
We were telling them, "No,
it's not accurate information.
It's a red herring that's
going to, basically,
tar and feather the
legitimate claims,"
and that's what
happened, unfortunately,
and the president, he
knew Giuliani way back,
so he was like, "Hey, this is
the guy who busted up the mob.
I'll just go with that guy,"
and some of us were telling him,
"That's not Rudy's
thing anymore, exactly.
He hasn't been in
court since 1992,"
and unfortunately,
that's what happened,
and so there's hearings going on
about sanctions
issues, et cetera.
They got distracted
by the shiny object.
I always say every great
crime needs a great patsy
and they fell for the great
patsy rather than looking,
but that didn't mean
there was no crime.
There were a lot of
constitutional issues
with the election
that, unfortunately,
the Supreme Court
ultimately didn't take up,
I think in part because
these other claims
were so outlandish that it
made a lot of judges say,
"I don't want to get
anywhere near this."
- In essence, if Sidney
Powell or Lin Wood
or some of those guys had
not been running around
with the more outlandish stuff,
like Dominion voting
machines related to Venezuela
and it's a plan that's
been going on for,
if they had not run with that,
you think that there
was enough stuff
to at least get cases
that would have been heard
instead of just they threw
everything out, basically.
- Exactly.
We were that close to getting
the Georgia Secretary of State
to voluntarily give us
a whole bunch of stuff,
and the moment Lin Wood
did his press conference
where he said a
lotta crazy stuff
and then Sidney followed
up with her stuff,
he was like, "Oh, I'm not
getting anywhere near this,"
that somehow the whole court
system and the legal class
and even a bunch of
congressmen were like,
"Okay, you're asking
me to associate
with allegations of
the ghost of Chavez
and China and Iran
and there's secret
servers in Germany,"
and I kept telling everybody
on that side of the aisle,
I was like, "Even
if you believe that,
no one else is going
to believe that,
so let's focus on
our good claims,
not get to the wild claims,"
but the wild claims sucked
up all the energy in the room
and killed it.
- Right, and the thing
that was so crazy about it
was not just all of the
claims and everything else,
but then for those of us
that try to analyze
this stuff honestly,
I kept saying all along, I said,
"Look, if Sidney Powell, who
has a pretty good track record,
if she's just
self-immolating right now,
if she's just making
crazy stuff up
and gonna pour gasoline
on herself and burn up,
then at the end,
we'll know that,"
and in a weird way, I suppose
that is what happened.
Here we are. Here we are.
- Exactly, but in the process,
people overlooked the fact
that there were a bunch
of people who voted
who don't appear to have
been qualified to vote,
and what I mean by
constitutionally qualified
is that the Constitution gives
to the state legislatures
exclusive control over
the entire voting process
for the presidency,
and the state legislature said
these people couldn't vote,
and yet a lot of these
states allowed 'em to vote.
They said they couldn't
vote by this method,
and they, I'll give an example.
Arizona, they just did a
small signature match check.
It came back that 30 times
more signatures didn't match
according to the
Democrats' own expert
than was the margin
of victory in Arizona.
If we had got
signature match checks,
when I talked to the president,
right out of the gate I said,
"If they'll give you
signature match checks,
the election is
on the up and up.
If they won't,
that means they're scared
that there's problems."
No state would allow a
signature match check to occur.
- What was their argument
for not allowing you?
Was it simply just like,
"We're the Democrats and
we got what we wanted,
so (laughing)"?
- Originally, they didn't
have good arguments
and then their arguments became
Sidney Powell's allegations.
They're like, "We're not gonna
dignify these crazy claims,"
and so forth.
They used that as their best
cover, their best fig leaf,
because I'll give an example.
The Georgia Secretary of
State promised back in 2018,
when he digitized
all the ballots
with the contract with
Dominion, he said,
"What's great about this
is we'll now print ballots
to the entire world.
We can publish every
ballot to the whole world
and everybody can see how
clean the election is."
One of the first
things I asked him
when I came down for
the president was,
"Why don't, so let's
go ahead and do that,"
and he's like, "I'll
get back to that."
He never got around to it,
which means there's
something in those ballots
that's unusual.
There's something
in those ballots
that will lead people to say,
"Hmm, why does it look that way?
Why does it have this problem?"
and I can already tell
you what some of them are.
Some of them, from
the ballots we saw,
there were people who
were writing in names
and signing in ways that were
completely contradictory.
You could look at him and say,
"That's probably not
the same person,"
and unfortunately, those really
good claims got swamped out
by the bad claims.
- Do you think that
the states like Arizona
that's doing some
audit stuff now
and Georgia now is
trying to pass some laws
that everyone of
course is saying are
racist and everything,
are any of these laws to
tighten up the roles, show IDs,
basic things that are being
called tools of white supremacy,
you think this stuff can work?
- Oh, absolutely.
We've identified a wide range
of weaknesses in the system
that were exploited in 2020
that are now getting corrected
in most states in the country.
Not all states, California
is going more crazy,
but every place else,
for the most part,
is actually tightening
down the laws,
especially in these
key swing states.
Wisconsin acknowledged that
they're not gonna allow
that same thing to happen again.
Michigan is saying they're not
gonna allow the same thing.
Georgia. Arizona.
Pennsylvania is
about to do an audit,
and I am for all audits.
It's what I tell my
friends on the left.
We should always have audits
so everybody has confidence
in the election outcome.
This isn't about right or left.
This is about having confidence
that the election was
done on the up and up,
and what better way to do
so than a transparent audit?
What I tell people throughout
was when the state kept saying,
"Don't worry,
everything's fine,"
that's like asking
Bernie Madoff,
"Have you taken a
look at your books?"
and Bernie came back and said,
"Yeah, my books are still good."
(Dave laughing)
That's not the way we do it.
We give an audit and that's
the way we should do it.
- You mean you don't let
the guy audit himself?
That's not how it works?
- Precisely.
You don't let the people
accused of doing something wrong
be the ones to tell
you, "No, don't worry.
Everything's cool."
- How is this, what we're
talking about right now,
directly related to
the Trump lawsuit?
Because obviously, as you know,
there's a slight chance that
YouTube won't let us post this
that you're saying right now.
We know that that
is a possibility.
That could be directly related
to Trump's lawsuit, right?
- Absolutely, and one of the,
what a bunch of us are
telling Trump's team
to add to the lawsuit
is to add two components
on the election aspect.
One is add all the
Hunter Biden stuff,
all the suppression
of Hunter Biden.
That was Big Tech censorship
at the request of
a political party
and arguably state actors.
I think they'll find proof.
- Right, that one seems
like the more obvious one,
that clearly they couldn't
have just decided,
everyone at once, no,
you can't talk about the laptop
and we're not gonna
let the "New York Post"
print journalism.
- Arguably, the biggest coverup
of a presidential election
political scandal
in American history,
and so I would've included that.
I would've included
it as a lot of this
were really illicit in-kind
campaign contributions.
Then you tie in
the election aspect
because a lot of these
election rule changes
were being funded
by Mark Zuckerberg.
He was privately financing
various clerks, election clerks,
to change the rules
throughout the country.
Why not add that to the lawsuit?
Because then you
have a robust lawsuit
that gets to all
of these scandals,
that entitles you to a
wider range of discovery,
gives you a better argument to
get past motions to dismiss,
and I think the president
would be legally entitled
to bring all of them.
- He's personally
suing these guys too?
He's personally
suing Zuckerberg?
How does that even
become part of this?
- What could have been the suit.
Right now, the way it's drafted,
it's highly likely that those
claims will be dismissed.
I think what Trump
was thinking about,
where they could amend the
complaint to properly allege it,
is that the way he saw this
is this didn't go from state
actor direct to Big Tech
and then to Zuckerberg,
it went from state actor
to Zuckerberg to Facebook.
He's not suing Zuckerberg,
if he does it right,
he's not suing Zuckerberg
because of what Facebook did
for which Zuckerberg could
not be individually sued
under the corporate veil,
but he's suing him because
Zuckerberg was using
his power over Facebook at
the request of the state
to control the public dialogue
and manipulate the
outcomes of the election.
- Is part of the problem
here that we know
that people can lie to
Congress and nothing happens?
The famous James Clapper
scratching the top of his head,
"We do not wittingly spy
on the American people,"
flat out lie and now
he's a CNN contributor,
or Jack Dorsey at Twitter
basically telling Ted Cruz,
"We don't shadow ban,"
and it's like, you obviously do,
but of course, I know with
a word like shadow ban,
it doesn't have a
technical definition,
so he can probably wiggle
out of it that way,
but the point is that you
can lie to Congress now
and it just doesn't matter.
- Yeah, unless you're
Roger Stone, (laughing)
unless you're the
wrong political party,
then maybe the law will matter
suddenly, but absolutely,
that's the bifurcated,
two-tiered system of justice
that the Department of
Justice has accelerated
in the Trump era is one of
the greatest risks and threats
to justice and its integrity
and the perception
of its integrity
amongst the broader public.
- Yeah. All right.
Election, Trump, okay.
Maybe my YouTube
channel's here, maybe not.
Either way, I'll be just
fine thanks to Locals.
What else is on your mind
right now on the legal front?
- I think the biggest issue,
the biggest case
that I have coming up
is gonna be the Kyle
Rittenhouse case
because this is the
right of self-defense,
which to me, the
Second Amendment is
not so much about guns,
it's about the right
of self-defense.
The most effective
means of self-defense
is to have access to a
method of self-defense,
being a gun ownership,
but what the Second
Amendment's really about
is your right to defend yourself
against either the
state or other citizens
in order to secure your
property and your liberty,
and there's probably no more
pure act of self-defense
than what Kyle Rittenhouse did,
and the fact they're trying
to put him in prison for life
is one of the greatest risks
and threats to self-defense
in American legal history
and that trial is
coming up this November.
- And it was being cheered
on by the mainstream media
as if he was a
white supremacist.
Of course, there's no evidence
that he's a white supremacist,
but could you just back up,
and I showed the
video on the show,
but for people that don't
really remember the case,
this was in Kenosha,
can you just explain
to people what happened
and actually what
he's charged with?
- Sure.
Kyle Rittenhouse is a son
of a working-class nurse,
a single mom,
who, to give you an
idea of who he is,
he went back and forth
when he was young
to wanting to do some sort
of military or police work
or be a nurse.
He's a guy who sees
himself as a protector,
as someone who rushes
into a traumatic situation
and tries to heal the situation.
That's who he is by personality.
That's who he is by biography.
- And that's, by the way,
what he said in videos
that day, right before,
that that's why he was there.
He was not there to hunt
anyone down or shoot anybody.
He was there to help,
meaning if people
were being assaulted.
- Completely, and while
people saw the gun that he had
for self-defense and for the
defense of property and others,
what he also had on him was
a bunch of nursing equipment
and nursing materials
to help people.
What happened in Kenosha was
after there was a
misrepresentation
in what happened
in the Blake case,
where they thought the
police officer did something
different than what
was actually the case,
as it ultimately turned out,
so it was one of those sort
of fake BLM narratives,
that all of a sudden they
started having riots,
they started burning
down the city.
Kenosha is a working-class
town on the border of Illinois
and in between
Milwaukee and Illinois.
They were burning
down businesses,
and what a lotta
people don't know
is most businesses don't
have arson insurance
or particularly riot insurance.
Riot's often an exception
under their insurance policies.
These were businesses
that were small businesses
that were wiped out forever,
no means of recompense,
and this was happening day
after day, night after night.
The Democratic governor was
letting it happen, frankly,
not calling in the
National Guard.
A bunch of local
people in the community
went out that night and
said, "Let's protect people,"
and what Kyle did was
let's protect people
and I'm gonna be able to try
to help people who get hurt,
and so he goes out
there and that night,
the first person that,
he gets different
attacks on him,
and then finally, he gets this
one guy who chases him down,
throwing things at him.
People are firing
guns behind him.
- There's video of all
of this, by the way.
- All of it, exactly.
Grabs the gun, tries to
pull the gun away from him.
He ends up getting shot.
By the way, this
guy was suicidal.
He had been previously convicted
of a bunch of horrendous crimes.
He had tried to kill
himself repeatedly.
He'd just been let out
of a mental institution.
That was the mindset of this
individual who attacked him
and he put things into motion.
I think if that guy had
got that gun that night,
there'd be a lot of
other people dead
'cause he's got a mass
shooter kind of psychology.
Kyle probably saved a lot of
other people's lives that night
just by defending himself
in that situation.
Then Kyle was
trying to run away,
trying to run towards police,
when he gets chased
by more people.
He gets thrown to the ground.
People attack him
with a skateboard.
Another other person
comes at him with a gun.
One person he shoots that dies,
one person he
shoots gets harmed,
but in both cases,
they're grabbing his gun,
trying to pull it away from him.
While one person is
trying to shoot him,
another person's
trying to hit him.
After that happens,
he's still in shock.
He runs towards the
police, gives himself up.
They tell him to go home,
and then he gets charged
with multiple counts
of intentional homicide and
attempted intentional homicide,
where they're trying to
put him in prison for life,
even though everybody,
including "The New York Times,"
who broke down the video, said
this is one of the cleanest,
clearest cases of self-defense
they've ever seen.
- I actually missed that
from "The New York Times"
'cause the most of
the media that I saw
was just this kid's
a white supremacist.
That's what it was.
He was a white
supremacist, in essence,
hunting down black people,
even though it's all on video.
- All these false stories.
This kid comes from a family
with family members
of multiple races.
They did a deep dive on
all of his social media.
They did a colonoscopic kind
of review of his social media
and they found no connections
to any form of
racism of any kind,
no connections to
militia of any kind,
no connections to anybody
like that of any kind,
no statements like
that at any time.
All they had was that he had
once gone to a Trump rally.
That was their sole basis,
the, "Oh, you went
to a Trump rally,"
and like most-
- Well, there you go.
- Exactly, and he's
a gun supporter
and he's a police,
military supporter,
and that was it, but
all they just did,
most of the media ran with
these false allegations,
these stream of false,
to this day, they continue
to tell false stories,
the prosecutors continue
to lie about 'em
using court proceedings
to get away with the lie.
The kid's the most innocent
defendant I've ever represented,
ever been involved with,
but the case goes far past him.
If he gets convicted,
self-defense is dead in America.
- How worried are
you, in general,
that the reality and the
evidence of cases like this
actually don't matter anymore
and what really matters
is public opinion
or pressure put on by the mayor,
or we saw that the City
of Minneapolis paid out,
I think it was $26 million,
if I'm not mistaken,
to George Floyd's family before
the verdict of the trial,
that really, the theater
has far more to do
with what happens than
the reality of the case.
- What I've been taught,
what I teach a lot
of young lawyers
is the court of public opinion
often matters a lot more
than the court of law,
that you can lose a case in
the court of public opinion
before you can ever win
it in the court of law,
and that was what's
critical in Kyle's case.
It was critical to
get all these false,
there's a reason why
prosecutors keep lying about him
in court over and over again.
It's because they
know that those lies
will be repeated by the media,
which will get back
to the jury pool
and the judges and
the politicians,
which will all have some role
in how Kyle's case is done.
That's why you have to defend,
the US Supreme Court
said 40 years ago,
"A competent lawyer
must defend his client
in the court of public opinion
to actually be an
effective representative
of his client."
That's where the court of
public opinion is critical
and that's where a lot
of people who think
they may be powerless don't
underestimate their own power.
Their participation in the
court of public opinion
ultimately shapes the
outcome of these cases.
- When you talk to some
of the prosecutors,
like off the record,
if you're having a whiskey
with one of these guys after,
do they realize how evil
what they're doing is
or they just believe it's
just part of the process?
- For some of them, they
actually believe in it.
They're politically ambitious,
politically aspirational.
There are people who
will just do any,
they believe the ends
justify the means.
It's the whole sort of new left.
The new left is not like
your old classical liberal
who believed in the
process for its own sake.
This new left believes
the process is ridiculous.
The process is solely there
to achieve a certain objective
and that's why they have no,
like hypocrisy means
nothing to them.
Unlike Dante's
bottom level of hell,
in their level of hell,
(Dave laughing)
hypocrisy takes you to heaven.
It's a whole different mindset
and a lot of 'em actually
celebrate their misconduct,
celebrate their malfeasance.
The Rittenhouse prosecutor
is one of the most
unethical prosecutors
I've ever witnessed.
- You mentioned related
to defunding the police
and how, in Kenosha,
that we've seen this in
so many of these cities,
that they're just,
the law enforcement is not
doing what it's supposed to do.
As you know, I'm still
here in crazy LA.
We've got a DA, this
guy George Gascon,
Bernie-backed DA,
middle-aged white
guy who got rid of
our first female black DA,
not that I care about that,
but I thought the identity
politics, people do.
In any event, he is
doing exactly what he did
in San Francisco before,
which is exactly what
Chesa Boudin is doing
in San Francisco now,
where they are just choosing
not to prosecute certain crimes.
I'm not a legal expert,
but at this point,
this is seeming criminal to me.
When they get sworn in,
it's to defend the laws,
and they're just picking which
laws they're not defending.
Do they need to be sued?
There's recalls in place,
but is this not just like
the most obvious
dereliction of duty?
- I think there should
be more legal remedies.
Our current courts make
it almost impossible
to ever sue prosecutors,
but it's like the Texas
sheriff suing Biden
over refusal to enforce
immigration laws.
The same thing because what
they're really doing is
they're weaponizing
a criminal class.
It's kinda like
early 1920s Russia,
that the immediate,
the initial stage of
the Soviet revolution,
they often weaponize
the criminal class
to side with them in
the ongoing civil war
that took place post-1917.
That's what they're
kind of doing here.
It's kind of what they did
with the Black Panthers
in the late '60s, early '70s.
People don't know how
much they were embedded
with drug dealers and
criminal operations.
The thought process was
this can be our own
political street army,
allowing them to extend
their political power,
like "Escape from L.A."
might soon be a documentary
rather than just a film,
(Dave laughing)
but that's the mindset.
- It's the name
of my documentary.
- Deservedly so
because this is insane
what's taking place.
When people can't
even go into a,
why would you even buy anything
anymore under 1,000 bucks?
You're walking in and
you see somebody walk in,
steal a bunch of stuff
and walk right out.
This is just insanity,
but what does it promote?
It promotes disrespect
for the law.
What that produces is
1970s-level crime problems,
and now politically, that almost
always leads to a backlash,
but in the interim, a lot
of working-class people
are the primary
people to suffer.
It's not the Westside,
Beverly Hills crowd
that's gonna suffer,
it's the South Central
and East LA folks
who are gonna suffer,
- To be clear, right
now in New York City,
because of their ridiculous DA,
you are allowed to
jump the turnstile.
If you are paying to
get on the subway,
you're basically a sucker.
We're saying, "Hey,
why are you paying?
Just get on your good high
tops and jump that thing,"
and then here in LA
or San Francisco,
you are now allowed to trespass.
I think it's $800 that you're
allowed to steal from a store.
I always tell people,
"You can get a PlayStation
5 with four games.
You can't get five games, then
you're over the threshold.
Then you can be in trouble,"
but it's like you're
encouraging people
to break the law, basically.
- And I would have more
respect for them if they said,
"We'll prosecute anybody
who steals less than 2,000,
but let anybody off who
steals more than 10,000,"
(Dave laughing)
because then they would be
down on Rodeo
Drive, but instead,
they're basically asking,
I have a client that's a
Mexican American shop owner
that owns little grocery
stores throughout East LA.
They're the number ones who
are people victimized by this.
This doesn't help
working-class people.
This hurts working-class,
honest people,
and rewards the criminal class
for the benefit of
a political class
and that's why it's
very dangerous,
but its politics is not even
what they pretend it to be.
- What about when
we see Democrats,
I think Kamala Harris
actually, as a candidate,
it was before the
election had taken place,
she was actually helping fund
some of these antifa people
get out of jail in Minneapolis
and some other places.
They are breaking laws,
but for some reason,
antifa is still on Twitter
and everywhere else.
Trump's gone, but
they're everywhere,
and that we actually
have politicians
that are raising money
to help criminals
that burn down stores and
attack cars on the street
to get out of jail.
- Yeah, it's extraordinary.
The last time we had anything
like this was late 1960s,
when you had people in bed
with the Black Panthers,
in bed with, actually,
Weather Underground,
in bed with a wide range of,
there was a different
revolutionary name
every other week.
People forget the Crips,
actually it's the Committee
for Revolution or whatever.
It was smart.
You're a local gang and you're
like, "Oh, we just rebrand.
(Dave laughing)
We rebrand as political
and now we can steal
stuff and kill people
and everything's
okay, it's kosher,"
but that's the same, we
brought back that mindset.
It was a disaster last time.
I don't know why anybody
believes it's gonna be anything
other than a disaster this time.
- What kind of backlash do
you think we're gonna see
on this stuff?
- If the 1970s are any preview,
you're gonna see "Dirty
Harry" style backlash.
You're gonna see, like J.
D. Vance's grandmother,
her hero was Dirty Harry
because of growing up
in that politically.
That's why she had
that .44 next to her,
even when she couldn't
physically lift it
later on in life.
I think that's the kind of
mindset you're gonna see.
You're gonna see
more and more people,
and I hope they
don't go too far.
I hope people, civil
rights are important,
those are sometimes
violated by police actors,
and sometimes in the '70s,
people were so mad
at the lawlessness
that they greenlit
some abusive behaviors.
I think we need to
find the right balance
in countering what's taking
place by the left currently.
- Do you think it's
possible that the cities
just aren't gonna work anymore,
like New York City, for example,
where I lived for most of
my adult life, 20 years.
I loved, loved, loved,
loved New York City.
If you can make it there,
you can make it anywhere.
I think everyone, until
these last couple of years,
I would say that
everyone in America
should live there
for a little while
just to get a taste
of that thing,
but the idea of being there now,
where at any given moment,
they can attack
you on the street
if you're sitting
at a restaurant,
or they can break
into the store,
or hop the subway thing,
or the litany of
other things going on,
that maybe city life in a
political environment like this
just doesn't work.
- Just look at my
client, Amy Cooper,
'cause the background
you're describing
is the context they failed to
include in the media coverage.
She's just out to
help her dog run
and they'd shut
down the dog runs
in the name of COVID somehow,
so the only place she
could help get her dog run,
to even get outside during
this lockdown era last summer,
was in the park,
and so she's by herself early
in the morning in the park
and then suddenly
somebody jumps her,
says that they got some
little treats for her dog,
which would scare anybody,
particularly a young,
single woman in a city,
particularly in the environment
of what was happening
in New York at the time,
where crime was skyrocketing
and everything else,
and she reacts by just
wanting to call police,
and then she's blamed,
she's demonized,
she loses her job, she
has to leave the country,
she's blacklisted
from employment,
and originally, she was
criminally prosecuted
until I got the prosecutor
to dismiss all charges.
That's reality of
life in New York City.
What went from being a dream,
went, for someone like her,
a quiet kid on the spectrum,
to being an utter nightmare.
- That case, which we
also covered that one,
there's video, basically,
where she's telling the
guy to get away from her,
but of course, the
media framed it,
surprise, surprise, as if
she's a white supremacist
and this nice black
man just approached her
to play with the dog
and everything else.
Obviously, some of that
stuff will work out,
but when someone like her
gets fired from their job
from something like that,
what is the legal
recourse that they have?
'Cause it had nothing to
do with anything she did,
obviously, at the office.
- And completely demonized.
This was someone who was
one of the most successful
in her business,
sort of a math nerd, kind
of a quiet kid from Canada.
All of a sudden, not only
was she fired summarily
without any benefits and
without any severance,
lost all the benefits
that she'd been accruing,
she couldn't get a job
anywhere else in the industry
because her name
is now radioactive
because of these media lies
that have been told about her.
I think it was CBS
even ran with a story
saying she had been
convicted at one point.
I was like, they gave me
the case, ended up being,
she was not only,
was it all dismissed,
it was dismissed with
prejudice with no deal,
no diversion, no nothing.
This was an acknowledgement
by the City of New York
that it was a complete mistake
what the allegations
were against her
'cause the truth came out.
She had talked to the
cops at the scene.
She had clarified everything
without any question
or controversy.
What they didn't know
is that first time
when she's on the phone,
they couldn't hear her.
The phone was breaking up,
which if you understand that,
that's why she's panicking,
she's like, "There's nobody
coming to rescue me,"
and as to your point
as to that guy,
a week before when
he did the same thing
to an African American man,
that man almost beat him up
'cause that was their response,
but it gives you a sense
when you live in that
kind of environment,
where overnight you
can feel like you're in
Kafka's "The Trial"
then in the world and ripped
by crime and lockdowns,
New York City looks like
"Escape from New
York," John Carpenter,
instead of New York of dreams,
New York, the Big Apple,
New York, "Sleepless in
Seattle" kind of New York.
- That's also the thing.
It's like people were so
hyper-racialized right now
to think about
race all the time,
to realize that
everyone's got a camera,
to think that someone's
coming to get you
because crime is jumping,
that everyone is a
little bit jumpy,
but for the average
person that sees that,
I think what they think is,
"Oh, I'm never gonna
speak up about anything
because I don't want
to lose my job."
What advice would
you give to people
relative to keeping their jobs
but still being
able to speak up?
'Cause that's probably
the number one question
I get at this point.
"I don't want to lose my job."
- Yeah, what's interesting is
Michael Malice has a version of
curse than with your yes, sirs.
Figure out whatever
their conspiracy
theories are about you
and play into them
and then they'll be even
more terrified and whatnot.
There's a lot, and it's the
old Ralph Ellison phrase,
"Curse them with your yes,
sirs," from "Invisible Man."
I think for each person,
I don't impose on anybody
an obligation to be a hero.
You don't have to go out
and make a noble stand.
If you feel like you're in
a position where you can,
then I encourage people to do so
and lawyers like me will
help bring suits for 'em.
We're challenging mask mandates.
We're challenging
vaccine mandates.
We're challenging these
unconstitutional firings,
brought defamation claims
from everybody from
the Covington kids
to anybody that's been
politically targeted
for the wrong purposes,
currently suing Don Lemon
over some of his behavior,
so not afraid.
There's lawyers out there
that will be willing
to represent you and
justify your cause,
but that doesn't mean
you have to be a hero.
Do what makes the
most sense for you
and figure out the
best way you can both
assert your independence, care
about what you care about,
and still protect what
matters most to you,
and sometimes that
means protect your job.
- Are you worried that
we're gonna become just like
a society that everything
ends up in the courts?
Basically, that one side'll,
"The New York Times" will
call me a white supremacist
every other week and that I'm
sort of over it at this point,
and if anything, I use it
as fuel to keep attacking,
but the average person
that's just sick of this,
that we're gonna
start suing over words
and libel and slander laws
are very, very specific,
but that will just end up
in this place where it'll be
less and less people
will say what they think,
more and more lawsuits
will be there,
and the spirit of
the First Amendment
will just sorta crumble,
even if it's not
legally demolished.
- That's what I think,
that the court of public
opinion is critical
and how people
support independent
technology platforms,
content creators,
share those messages where and
when they feel comfortable,
look at the resistance
mechanisms that
people have employed
through every civil
rights movement in history
and there have been
successful ways to push back,
whether it's civil rights
for African Americans
or any other cause,
that the civil right,
you'll find they often use,
like people behind
the Iron Curtain
found ways to
communicate in secret,
found ways to get
out key messages,
found ways to resist in ways
little and small and big,
and sooner or later,
what people should remember
is the system can't,
the system needs the whole
four pillars of power,
sit on the fifth
pillar of power,
which is the perception
of the moral legitimacy
of the other four.
Take out that fifth
pillar of power
and the whole system crumbles,
and people should
remember their own,
nobody can close.
Big Tech cannot shut down
the archives of nature
and the rights of man,
and if we listen
to our conscience,
we can take action and that
can still change the world,
as it always has.
- Ah, Barnes, that should've
been your closing statement,
but I'm going for one more here.
You're definitely a lawyer.
That was a primo
closing statement.
I got one for you,
that I listen to you
and Viva all the time
and you guys are awesome,
but I don't know that
I've heard you talk
about this specifically.
At what point,
it's a two-parter,
at what point do you think
that the lefty
Democrats voted in,
I'm not talking about the DAs,
I'm talking about
AOC and Ilhan Omar
and Rashida Tlaib
and that whole crew
that are clearly undermining
the values of America,
at what point do you think
they're in dereliction
of their oath of office,
which is to defend
the Constitution of
the United States?
Because it seems to
me they're treading
as close as possible.
I get that it would be
almost impossible to prove,
but do you think there is
some sort of tipping
point with that?
If every message that you
send out is anti-American,
if you can't send out a
pro-Cuba demonstrator tweet,
none of them have because
they're kinda into communism,
at what point do you think
there is an actual dereliction
of what they've
sworn to protect?
- I see it as a twofold thing,
whether or not there's been
a dereliction of their duty
and then who has remedy for
that dereliction of duty.
When it comes to remedy,
I always favor elections
wherever possible,
the having the people
having control,
but so in terms of remedy for
their dereliction of duty,
that's what I believe
the remedy is,
but I believe, without question,
they've shown
dereliction of duty.
It's a version of confession
through projection.
Take a lot of AOC's and
other people's statements
about January 6th
and then change it from her
saying, "Ted Cruz did this,"
or, "That person did this,"
to her admitting she did it
related to all the things
that happened all summer,
and then she's actually
just confessing,
that really, "This is
a violation of oath.
This is a violation
of the Constitution.
This put people in danger.
I really shouldn't
be a Congressman.
They should lock me up."
All the things she's
saying about other people
are really confessions
of what she's done.
- Of course, we'd rather
this go to the ballot box,
but at some point I do feel
like they're gonna do something
that will push it to their side,
but my other question
related to this is
it seems to me,
I know I'm a crazy right-wing
conspiracy theorist,
but it seems to me that
something's not quite right
with Joe Biden,
and it seems to me that
pretty much everyone knows it,
and Joe Biden often
slips up and says,
"Oh, I'm gonna get in
trouble for saying this,"
and the question of course is,
who's he gonna get
in trouble with?
At what point is
that a legal issue?
That it seems that
everyone around Joe Biden
knows something's
not right with him,
and what I keep saying is at
some point, it's gonna break.
Something's gonna happen.
One of those moments that
he freezes into the camera
is gonna go on for
20 seconds longer
than the 20 seconds
it goes on now
or some other something,
and suddenly when
the dam breaks,
the rats are gonna have to
get off that ship so fast
and they're all gonna
turn on each other.
Everyone's gonna be like,
"No, no, I was the one.
I was the one that wanted
to wave and tell everybody
and tell the media
and all that stuff,"
and they will turn
on each other.
Could there end up being
like a real legal case
related to all of that?
- There is.
It's another case of
confession through projection
'cause you think about all
the allegations against Trump,
that there's family members
involved in corruption overseas,
that it involved foreign
illicit interference
in the election,
and that the president is
someone who is mentally ill
and should be removed for
Twenty-fifth Amendment purposes.
They basically were
describing Joe Biden,
and there's no question,
that is what the Twenty-fifth
Amendment is there for.
I think the problem
the political Democratic
establishment has,
I think they even thought
about using it at some point,
the problem is Kamala Harris is
so hated throughout the country,
they don't have a
popular replacement.
I think that
there's no question.
We have a live
dementia candidate
that people like Putin
get to make fun of
on a regular basis.
The North Koreans are making
fun of us, the North Koreans.
This is not good.
This is the sign
of where we're at.
It's a sign of a
declining empire.
Michael Malice calls it a
white pill 'cause he's like,
"Just look at it. Joe Biden
is the head of the empire.
How can you not feel optimistic
for the end of the empire?"
(Dave laughing)
There's some truth
to that, but yeah,
no, the Twenty-fifth
Amendment is there
for people like Joe Biden
who are clearly
constitutionally,
cognitively incapable
of exercising the
duties of their office.
- Barnes,
I look forward to continuing
this adventure with you.
- Absolutely.
- We got a lotta
work to do, right?
I always end my show these days
by saying we got work to do
and I got nothing better
to do than save the world.
- Exactly.
The way I see it is I tell
people it's like Paul Revere.
We're in his little silversmith
shop back in the 1760s
and the world might look
like doom and gloom,
but within a generation,
we had the greatest revolution
the world had ever seen.
- Robert Barnes, I
thank you, my friend.
- Glad to be here.
- If you're looking
for more honest
and thoughtful
conversation about law,
instead of the nonstop yelling
you get everywhere else,
check out our law playlist,
and if you want to
watch full interviews
on a variety of topics,
check out our full
episode playlist.
They're both right over here,
and to get notified
of all future videos,
be sure to subscribe and
click the notification bell.